yeah well I can see that what I'm
talking about is the mass amount of
pesticides are using what in tarnation
is going on around here Marley I'm
paying you to learn farming mechanics
just do I killed you know specifies
they're okay for many ways well sir I
think it's you who doesn't know anything
you're not learning about the harmful
effect these pesticides and herbicides
are causing me I know everything I don't
want you festivities oh I'm talking
about way bigger effects than you paying
for these no I'm talking about the
environmental damage and the damage to
the people who eat your products what in
tarnation I knew what I'd done Billy
shouldn't ain't no sand by the creek
earlier that's very true
you know pesticide and fertilizer runoff
can cause major damage to local habitats
well anyways so god they always go
inside and talk about this sure what
even is this place don't worry about it
so as I was saying whenever it rains the
rain water absorbs some of those
fertilizers are putting down and that
makes it seem even farther into the
ground where then get picked up by the
groundwater the groundwater shifts it
over to the local environment where it
taints the water supplies those tainted
water supplies in Gaza uncontrollable
algae blooms and harms the wildlife that
harm eventually comes back to you your
consumers and the people who eat the
wildlife well I'm proud to tell you that
we use organic nitrogen fertilizers
around here see my boss here is really
smart he knows what he's doing
well those solutions you're using aren't
actually addressing the root of the
problem which is you're allowing your
pesticides to seep into the groundwater
and affect the local wildlife so what do
you suggest that we do that
two words cellulose sponges sillas
punches how am I supposed to use in a
performance no dudes I'm off girls that
is correct senator fun jizz are known
for being very absorbent we don't for
being extremely resistant to temperature
and chemical weathering known to be a
great buffer material and they're 100%
eco-friendly you know how my supposed
Informer well the men that we use is
after harvesting your crops used to dig
about a five-foot hole beneath the area
that you've been cultivated once you've
done that you're gonna need to put in
one layer of steel filtration mesh once
you've done that put in a layer of our
Salo sponges coated with denitrifying
bacteria and soap on top of that without
another layer filtration mesh and you
can plan your cross on top of that oh
well I see why this one is their use but
why do you need the filtration ready
well the filtration mesh helps to
alleviate some of the pressure that's
been put on the sponges from the weight
of all your soil and crops it also makes
sure that the sponges don't biodegrade
as easily well I didn't want either one
on the bottom that helps make sure that
all the harmful materials have been
filtered out don't sleep back into the
environment oh I see oh darn diddly deee
so how does the technique here even work
well you see whenever it rains some of
that fertilizer is absorbed by the
rainwater that rainwater begins to seep
down farther into the earth it gets past
that first layer of the filtration mesh
and into these sponges now the sponges
again have D nitrifying bacteria inside
of them this D nitrifying bacteria
breaks down those ammonium nitrates
where you break them down well in
limited amounts they're good but in
those extensive amounts that you've been
using in those fertilizers they can
actually have some pretty serious side
effects well I can see how they're bad
but are we like really trying to like
prevent Meadows like arsenic and lead
for getting into the soil that's true
which is why we use a process called
cyclic electrowinning precipitation
where when you add an acid or a base
into a mixture of tainted water it can
remove those metals from the water for
this we're using the soap because of its
non corrosive capabilities and for its
base abilities Oh so overall what well
it ends up making your business much
more eco-friendly by removing all of
those harmful chemicals that are inside
your runoff and those harmful metals
well it's also big but all my supposed
to afford to this it sounds like it's
gonna cost a fortune
well it won't actually cost a fortune
how big is your farm I would say about
500 acres right Molly around there
yeah well I'm grow crops on 200 of those
pictures and like you need to rest
retching so I think all right well my
company is selling plots of sponges with
that D nitrifying bacteria in soap on a
50 by 50 foot plot of land for five
hundred dollars now judging by the size
of your farm you about three thousand
five hundred of those and for that
filtration man mesh that's only going to
be about $1200 per acre now all of the
layers of mesh in total are gonna cost
$500,000 adding up to a grand total of
2.25 million actually this system last
up to 25 years which means that you'll
only be paying $80,000 while it's in
effect
dang sucky it takes about 100 K for
fertilizer and the pesticide on our
farms that's way cheaper after today I
learned about the same little sponges
I'm gonna use these and make the
environment a better place while still
tending to my farm where every morning
well how do I maintain this is it like I
have to do well we'll provide a bat
filled with D nitrifying bacteria and
soap on the side of your farm it'll
saturate up one side of the sponges but
that saturation will spread to the other
sponges due to the absorption qualities
of the sponge so overall I just have to
fill out that bat like every few yeah
but that cost is very low that's very
interesting I'll consider you should it
can greatly decrease the environmental
impact that you have by reducing the
amount of ammonium nitrates in heavy
metals that are able to see into the
environment through your runoff that's
true
so we're gonna do boss you know where we
will yeah
you